meine Damen und Herren
die gute Nachricht gleich von der Website über
1.000 Tagen regiert in Deutschland Rot-Grün
und was soll ich Ihnen sagen als ich heute Morgen
aufstand da kam immer noch Strom aus der Steckdose
was kein Mensch geglaubt ist das rot-grüne Chaos
lässt die deutschen völlig kalt die Menschen gehen
nach wie vor morgens brav zur Arbeit haben
sie die Kneipe anschließend wahlweise ins
Bett oder auf Asylanten Jagd nicht einmal
die Bundeswehr hat sich aufgelöst oder ist
zum Feind übergelaufen okay zugegeben der
Verteidigungsminister ist inzwischen läufig
Rudolf Scharping mutiert mehr und mehr
zu einem Fleisch gewordenen Suchgerät
unser lieber toller Trottel der
Kompanie der steckt mitten im
johannes-trieb meine Damen und sie kennen
das vielleicht Johannes trieb das ist das
Frühlings Erwachen des Mannes in
der Blüte seine Arterienverkalkung
man muss
also wenn ein Verteidigungsminister sich derart
selber zur Fotostrecke bringt meine Damen und
Herren man muss schon fragen dürfen ob der noch
fällt Herr der Lage im eigenen Oberstübchen ist
es heißt ja immer so schön es gibt kein Recht
auf Faulheit ja bitte aber warum gibt es denn
ein Recht auf Dummheit und auf Dreistigkeit
was was veranstaltet dieser Mann da was was
will er uns beweisen ja ich meine diese
ganze mazedonien-einsatz muss ich das doch
mal fragen was was tun die da 150 Millionen
D-Mark 500 Soldaten sammeln 3300 Waffen ein
war von den Kosten abgesehen ja die NATO ist ganz
stolz dass sie die Waffen so fleißig abgeben wir
auch schon eine ganze Reihe neu dabei gewesen
hat die NATO gesagt ja klar was denken sie da
was da abläuft die Rebellen im Mazedonien
haben gesagt ja okay wie viel Waffen selber
abgeben 3300 kein Problem da haben die
ihre Lieferanten in Deutschland angerufen
hatte gebrauchte neu bestellt jetzt treffen diese
Waffe mit den Waffen Einsammler gleichzeitig in
Mazedonien ein und werden davon auch gleich hier
bei den rüstungscen im Lager abholen können ja
aber zumindest was Rudolf schapi
betrifft sollte der Kanzler eine
hormonhaushaltsperre verhängen meine Damen
und Herren überhaupt was für eine Regierung
ja der Verteidigungsminister ist ein spät
pubertierender Radfahrer der Außenminister
ist ein gelernter Taxifahrer dem völlig egal ist
wohin die Fahrt geht solange er am Steuer sitzt
und was ist der Kanzler was ist Gerhard
Schröder ist es unser Tony Blair oder doch
nur Deutschlands später einfach auf Bill Clinton
ich glaube er ist eine Mischung so eine blinden
wer hat früher das Politik kann man nämlich in
einem einzigen Satz zusammenfassen den hat er
selber gesagt da waren noch Ministerpräsident
in Niedersachsen es geht um den Verkauf
von U-Boot Blaupausen nach Südafrika also
Konstruktionspläne für U-Boote jetzt gibt es
diesen blöden Parteitag das Beschluss der SPD das
solche Kriegswaffen auf gar keinen Fall in Länder
wie damals in Afrika verkauft werden dürfen
weil das ist jetzt echtes Hintergrundwissen
Kriegswaffen verkaufen Sozialdemokraten
grundsätzlich nur an befreundete Diktatoren
Südafrika damals noch Apartheid als sie erinnern
sich da war mit dem Menschenrechten nicht alles
ganz im grünen Bereich es war jetzt nicht so
schlimm wie im Kosovo dass sie Naht wird da
eingreifen müssen oder das Rudolf Scharping
beunruhigt gewesen wäre aber es müssen schon
einzelne schwarze benachteiligt worden
sein die die SPD sagte jedenfalls eine
solche Länder liefern wir überhaupt keine
Waffen Herr Schröder das Zeug verkauft er
hat gesagt ist ein Arbeitsplätze bei uns und
da hat er recht Deutschland ist der viertgrößte
Waffenexporte der Erde wenn sie nur an nicht
Diktatoren liefern wollen haben sie Engpässe
sie müssen es wirtschaftlich sehen
wir leben in den Zeiten des globaler
die guten Minen die die bösen Serben
im guten Kosovo verbuddelt haben hat er
eine Tochterfirma von Daimler Benz hergestellt
natürlich haben die den Sabine nicht verkauft
um damit böse Dinge zu tun das würde ich da
noch nie unterstellen nein die haben gesagt
guck mal hier sehr schöne Tellermine
hängst du beim Kamin sieht cool aus
interessanterweise hat der Konzern eine
andere Tochter Firma Fahrzeuge herstellt
die wissen ja auch wonach Sie suchen und
dieses dieses Unternehmen wird auch dumm
jetzt wirtschaftlich gesehen wenn die nicht auch
an Fabriken mit dem Prothesen beteiligt werden
das sind doch alles Systemanbieter heutzutage
eine nachfrageschaffen und befriedigen das ist
wirtschaftliches Denken Schröder hat das
alles begriffen hat das Zeug verkauft und
da wurde er gefragt Herr Schröder klarer
Partei das Beschluss auf gar keinen Fall
Waffen in diese Länder und sie machen das und
da hat Schröder sein legendären Satz gesagt
die Frage ob ein einmal gefasst haben
prinzipieller Beschluss in jeder konkreten
Situation durchgehalten werden kann
muss differenziert betrachtet werden
das sind die tiefen Verwüstungen die der zweite
Bildungsweg hinterlassen kann meine Damen und
Konrad Adendorf legte das
gleiche zu sagen nur auf Deutsch
was geht mich mein Geschwätz von gestern an
aber die deutschen stehen auf der Typ bin oder
ist bis heute der beliebteste aller deutschen
Kanzler Beckenbauer auch so ein Dummschwätzer
der könnte auch sagen es geht nicht
mehr geschätzt vom vorigen Satz an
Lichtgestalt oder ja Christoph Daum der
alte Koks der den können sie vergessen
als Vorbild für die Jugend aber back im Bauer wenn
schon Fremdgehen dann auch ohne Gummi da
hat die eigene Ehefrau auch was davon ne
der Schröder begriffen was los ist rot grün gibt
den WLAN das was die wirklich gewollt haben das
Gefühl endlich tut sich was in diesem Land und
zwar ohne dass ich für mich irgendetwas ändert
der Mehltau ist weg der Reformstau ist
aufgebrochen es wird die ganze Zeit regiert die
haben eine Methode entwickelt absoluten Stillstand
als hektische Betriebsamkeit zu verkaufen
wenn sie bei Rot Grün mitreden wollen
dann müssen sie immer am bleiben ständig
bei Kohl konnten sie mal ja im Bett
bleiben da haben sie nichts verpasst
der hat ja nie reagiert der Kohl gab es wär cool
in 16 Jahren cool
warum der hat die Tests verhindert
der Kohl der kannte die deutsche